this video is sponsored by brilliant
start learning for free with the link in
the description and the first 200 get
20% off the annual premium subscription
in the early 1980s Britain began
discussing with China the future of its
last remaining major colony Hong Kong
immediately Beijing made clear in no
uncertain terms that it would neither
accept an independent Hong Kong nor a
Chinese one administered by Britain
instead it suggested an alternative a
temporary 50 year limbo as a separate
special administrative region of the PRC
this new never before tried proposal
raised many questions from the trivial
to the existential what flag would be
flown what currency would be used which
citizenship would they hold and how much
of Britain's presence would remain with
no guiding historical precedent with
which to refer as its neighbour Macau
had yet to be handed over by Portugal
the answers to these questions were wide
open legally only the New Territories
were least set to expire after 99 years
in 1997 the geographically smaller but
well-developed Hong Kong Island and
Kowloon Peninsula had been surrendered
in perpetuity
initially the British considered
retaining their rightful territory to
become a small independent state and as
proof of just how wide open the
possibilities there was even a slightly
serious proposal to resettle its five
million inhabitants in Northern Ireland
Beijing however soon reminded Britain
that the island received its water and
supplies from the mainland whose pipes
could easily be shut off thus at least
one question was answered all of Hong
Kong would become Chinese soil when the
lease expired in 97 of those remaining
that of citizenship something at the
very heart of identity proved to be
especially significant and contentious
until the 1960s all British nationals
whether born on the British Isles or one
of its overseas colonies like Hong Kong
were permitted to enter and stay in the
UK as full unrestricted citizens
as its Empire began unwinding in the 60s
and 70s however it feared an influx of
immigrants from its African and Asian
colonies new laws were passed making it
more difficult for these groups to enter
unless they or their families were quote
connected to the UK in 1981 the British
Nationality Act created three new
categories British citizens for
residents of the UK British overseas
citizens and for Hong Kong and other
crown colonies British dependent
territories citizens with this law
British citizenship was fundamentally
redefined to exclude millions of
overseas citizens from the right to
abode the ability to enter and stay in
the UK at will and without restriction
from then on Hongkongers were relegated
to a new form of literal second-class
citizenship in a thinly veiled attempt
to stop non-white immigration to the UK
and while this change was not solely
aimed at them it affected the territory
in a very unique way while citizens of
other colonies lost their right to abode
as they gain that of their new
independent country those in Hong Kong
were to be handed over to an existing
country whose commitments had not yet
been tested in the eyes of locals
Britain had betrayed them a feeling
which would only intensify as the years
went on because the city would soon no
longer be a British dependent territory
a new status was created specifically
for its special circumstance called the
British national overseas passport it
like its predecessor lacked the right to
abode in the UK but could only be
applied for before the handover the
Chinese though refused to accept the
embarrassing idea that Hong Kongers
would remain British nationals of any
kind
after 97 China insisted that at midnight
on the day of the handover all would
lose their British status and instantly
become Chinese nationals their old
passports could be used as travel
documents but not as proof of British
citizenship
then in 1989 the tanks of the People's
Liberation Army rolled into tan and Minh
square and the slowly growing collective
unease felt in Hong Kong reached a
tipping point a million stunned citizens
took to the streets whose fear of
uncertainty had become simply fear but
there was still some hope luckily the
British position was far from singular
the local Hong Kong government led by
its last Governor Chris Patten felt this
rising tension and lobbied Britain on
their behalf London expressed fear that
if it gave the be a no right to abode
three million immigrants might suddenly
flood the UK overwhelming its social
system this despite the fact that 30
million white Commonwealth citizens in
Australia Canada and New Zealand also
could have emigrated at any given time
it would be wrong they said to promise
the right to abode if they could not
fulfill these obligations in the event
of an emergency they also argued doing
so would violate its joint declaration
with China the document basis for the
handover and yet ten months later
Britain did just that
the British nationality selection scheme
gave full British citizenship to 50,000
hand-picked residents along with their
spouse and children under 18 this elite
group was chosen directly by the
governor and was based on four
categories of people including
professionals and civil servants
selection was based primarily on a point
system which rewarded among other things
English proficiency and connections to
the UK those not deemed important or
British enough by their colonizers were
simply out of luck still knowing of
these inadequacies Patten continued
lobbying increasingly finding himself
caught between locals and officials in
Britain ironically both sides made the
same accusation locals suggested not
giving the right to abode was assigned
Britain must not be confident in Hong
Kong's post handover prospects if it
genuinely feared a mass exodus at the
same time Britain argued that giving the
right to abode was a sign patent wasn't
confident in his negotiations with China
since otherwise it wouldn't be necessary
amidst this larger debacle Lord Paton
also fought to resolve to
unusual complications first Chinese law
stated that only ethnically Chinese
Hongkongers would automatically become
Chinese nationals at the time of the
handover
but the bno passport was acquired by
application meaning that if one were not
ethnically Chinese and did not apply for
the bno passport at the time of the
handover their dependent territory
citizenship status would expire but the
Chinese would refuse to naturalize them
leaving them effectively stateless one
Indian family in particular had lived in
British Hong Kong for sixty years
received British education 'he's spoke
with british accents and yet only some
were granted full british citizenship
while their brothers and sisters or not
even after learning of these
circumstances the British Home Office
held the position for years that they
would simply become British overseas
citizens and that if they were indeed
forced out of Hong Kong
Britain would then consider them for
immigration only in the last year before
the handover did Britain finally
acquiesce second was the question of
visas a new Special Administrative
Region passport would be created for
after the handover featuring the same
national emblem and illustration of the
great wall as that of the mainland the
question was whether its holders would
be given visa-free access to the UK here
to the British Home Office pushed back
suggesting anti-immigration voters would
make no distinction between the right to
abode and visa-free access Patten in
turn countered that not doing so would
infuriate the Chinese who would lobby
for fewer rights for the bno passport
making it even less valuable Hong Kong
would also likely impose visa
restrictions on its 400,000 annual
British visitors after much
back-and-forth Beijing assured them that
the SAR passports would only be
available to holders of permanent hong
kong ID cards only in hong kong and only
by hong kong immigration authorities
six-month visa free access was secured
and the Prime Minister announced we in
Britain will have continuing
responsibilities to the people of Hong
Kong and will be watching to see that
the letter and spirit of the joint
declaration
are honored now next year and for 50
years beyond words deliberately chosen
to prevent any future British politician
from reneging or at least to make a fool
of anyone who tried these two rare
successes in the long drawn-out lead-up
to the handover were celebrated but
still left what many considered the
largest source of unease the status of
the bno passport this tension became
palpable in the final months before the
handover as tens of thousands stood in
line to register for the British
passport 24 hours before the deadline
finally the day came on July 1st 1997
after nearly two decades of negotiations
vague promises worry and skepticism Hong
Kong became China citizenship however
always remained contentious and in the
eyes of many an unforgiveable black mark
on Britain's legacy it has even since
been revealed that Britain asked
Portugal not to give full citizenship to
Macao residents which would make it look
bad in comparison some who renounce
their British citizenship in a pledge of
support to China others lost credibility
for holding foreign passports which some
said undermine their claims of loyalty
over time the bno passport once seen as
a valuable insurance policy became more
of an expensive piece of paper compared
to the Hong Kong SAR passport it's three
times as costly offers 48 fewer
visa-free countries and territories and
perhaps most embarrassing is less useful
when entering the UK while Hong Kong
passports allow expedited immigration
holders of the bno fill out landing
cards and enter the UK like any other
foreigner they also can't apply for
Australian visas online and are banned
from becoming chief executive most of
its holders will never have use for its
few benefits like the right to join the
British Armed Forces and get married
under British law and as one final nail
in the coffin because China views the
B&O as merely a travel document it does
not allow its holders British consular
access anywhere on Chinese soil whether
on the mainland Macao or Hong Kong
in practice the B&O is similar to the
status of those born in American Samoa
to non-us citizen parents despite being
on American soil such a person is
regarded as a US national but not a US
citizen and thus not allowed to vote
serve on a jury or apply for restricted
government jobs although unlike B&O
holders they do have the right to reside
in any part of the country
that is until possibly now after Beijing
announced a national security bill which
will outlaw secession subversion and
terrorism against the Chinese national
government in Hong Kong Britain
responded that it's now 23 years later
reconsidering the rights of bno
passports so far it's offered to extend
visa-free stays from 6 to extendable
periods of 12 months allowing for work
and study and creating a path for
citizenship although this applies to all
roughly 3 million holders of the
passport whether or not they're
currently renewed as well as their
dependents it leaves out the majority of
its population given that the bino could
only be applied for before 1997 and
can't be passed down those under 23 a
large swath of Hong Kong's protesters
will likely be ineligible many details
are yet unknown will these rights be
extended to all residents what exactly
will be the criteria for permanent
citizenship and how will China retaliate
in the absence of any answers to these
questions many see Britain's offer as
more political than practical in truth
the right to abode was always
misunderstood as a debate about
immigration when in fact it was one of
confidence rather than encouraged
migration it was always intended to
prevent it Patten knew the health of
Hong Kong's bureaucracy would be left in
the hands of a relatively small number
of highly educated well-off individuals
the right to abode was about instilling
the confidence necessary to keep them in
Hong Kong after the handover along with
their democratic ideals it would also
act as a check on Beijing the knowledge
that it may lose the city's most
talented if it did not keep them
satisfied indeed famously in the years
before the handover hundreds of
thousands of Hong Kongers
to Canada Australia the US UK and
elsewhere their reasons however are
largely misunderstood some of course
stayed abroad where they established
Cantonese as the language of Chinatown's
many on the other hand stayed only long
enough to gain citizenship before
returning to Hong Kong with this new
insurance plan this is so common in fact
it has a name the return tide of Hong
Kong an estimated 35 percent of those
who left in the 80s returned later
another astronaut refers to one family
member usually the father who stayed
making money in Hong Kong while the rest
of the family lived abroad in Vancouver
Sydney San Francisco or elsewhere to
gain citizenship such is the predicament
of Hongkongers they love their city
their language and their way of life
they want above all else and as long as
possible to stay and yet they also know
these things are temporary
now just as foreign passports act as a
sort of insurance plan for Hongkongers a
strong understanding of math science and
especially computer science is the
universal insurance plan that can help
you earn better grades get better jobs
and write out recessions like the one
we're currently in brilliant holds the
philosophy that most of these topics are
really best learned a little bit at a
time every day over weeks or months it
takes big topics like cryptocurrency
solar energy and vector calculus breaks
them down into small interactive
exercises and explains them in a way
that actually makes sense
brilliant gives you a new puzzle or
problem to solve every day on it's
beautifully made mobile app and website
where you can also ask questions discuss
solutions and dive deeper into whatever
topic interests you most start learning
today for free with a link in the
description the first 200 people will
also get 20% off the annual premium
subscription